Andalucia is a place with so much
history and interesting things to
discover
it's a place where different cultures
and religions have and still do
influence the landscape and nowhere is
this more apparent than in the very
famous mosque Cathedral of Cordoba a
place where Islam and Christianity meet
and where we can experience the course
of history quite literally as we walk
its incredibly beautiful Halls
so what is the actual history of this
fascinating building
[Applause]
the southern parts of Spain and Portugal
often called Andalucia or al-andalus in
Arabic was ruled by Muslim dynasties for
more than half a millennium the
arab-blad armies first entered the
Iberian Peninsula in the year 711 very
easy to remember and it was the umayyad
Empire that would first establish its
rule here especially after Abdul Rahman
the first was forced to flee from
Damascus with the Abbasid Revolt in the
East abdulrahman established al-andalus
as a center for the Umayyads with the
city of Cordoba at its very center a
position that it would hold for many
centuries thereafter
it was also abdulrahman the first that
began the construction of the great
mosque in the city around the year 756.
This was meant to be at the center of
religious life for Muslims in the region
where communal Friday prayers will be
held every week
the umayyad Empire and eventually
caliphate grew into a very significant
political and cultural force over the
coming centuries and Cordoba was at the
very center of all of this
here Arts literature Sciences music and
other fields would flourish and the
period is famous as being one of
intellectual openness and a relative
tolerance shown towards other religious
groups like Christians and Jews all of
whom were taking part in the sharing of
ideas
subsequent Kings and caliphs of the
umaya dynasty would add and expand the
great mosque as the population of the
city grew abdulrahman II added a section
and all the way in the 10th Century
calebs like Abdul Rahman III al-haqam II
and the vizier al-mansour expanded the
mosque into a huge structure with a
shape that we recognize today with a
large Courtyard in the fountain from
making ablutions the famous columned
Halls on the inside and of course a
towering minaret
it really was a quite impressive
building and played an important role in
the lives of Muslims living in this
Cosmopolitan City one of the most
prosperous in the world at the time it
continued to play its Central role
during the umayyad period until the
collapse of the empire in the mid 11th
century when it fell apart into smaller
States known as talifas even later with
the establishment of new unifying
Empires like the almoravids and the
al-mahads Cordoba and its mosque never
really retained its former glory the
al-mahads chose as their Capital the
city of Sevilla or Seville making that
City the new center for politics and
culture
but still Cordoba remained an important
city and its great mosque was still in
use over the centuries it was here that
all the great figures would have come to
pray from the famous calebs and leaders
some of which we have mentioned to Great
Scholars philosophers and Mystics like
IBN masara IBN hazam IBN rust or
aberries and of course even Arabi it
really is amazing to walk the halls and
know that so many great figures once
stood in this very spot kneeling and
prostrating in devotion
but the building story doesn't end here
in 1236 the Christians conquered Cordoba
as part of the so-called Reconquista
the city was now ruled by another
religion and its most important
religious building was thus to undergo a
significant change
but the great mosque wasn't demolished
or destroyed to build a new church as
would often be the case elsewhere
instead the Christians used the very
same building and remade it into a
cathedral
over the years new features were added a
beautiful Chapel right in the middle of
the building in the 14th century a
Gothic Nave in the 15th and a very
impressive Renaissance section that
fills the space with lights and scale
even the old minaret was transformed
into a bell tower
at the same time many of the features of
the old mosque still remained making
this a truly unique building today on
top of still being used by Christian
devotees it has become basically a kind
of Museum one of the most popular
tourist attractions in the region and
for good reason it's an absolutely
fascinating and beautiful artifact of
history but also to the evolving
religious and spiritual Sentiments of
the city's inhabitants throughout that
history
for a long time it served as the great
Mosque of one of the Muslim world's most
important cities the seat of power for
the umayyad caliphate later it became a
cathedral used by Christians in their
religious services and all of this is
visible today since the building and its
different features from across history
are remarkably well preserved as you
walk in you are struck with the
incredible and iconic columns and their
horseshoe arches built all the way back
in the 8th century and of course later
expanded
the prayer Niche on the far end of the
al-hakim extension toward which the
whole congregation would face as they
prostrated in the direction of Mecca
you can look at the very same beautiful
inlays and details that thousands of
Muslims included some of the greatest
historical figures would have seen as
they prayed
but at the same time you can also see
the very strong Christian Heritage too
the beautiful marble Renaissance ceiling
the images of Jesus an important figure
in both religions after all and various
small chapels along the walls containing
images of Saiyans as well as various
scenes and Relics even as you step out
into the courtyard among the orange
trees and look at the tower you can
experience the course of history
what used to be the minaret is now a
bell tower and we can see aspects of
both at the same time with the bottom
half still retaining its original
Islamic form with an added tower on top
in a very similar way to the so-called
hiralda in Seville which is pretty much
an identical history with most of the
structure being from the old minaret but
with modifications on top
the mosque Cathedral of kodoba or
mosquito as it is known locally is truly
one of the marvels of the world when it
comes to historical buildings and places
it is a product of the great
civilization of al-andalus and the
different changes that have taken place
here both politically culturally and
religiously it is a mosque it is a
cathedral and it is a museum a reminder
of a complicated and dynamic past of
intellectual flowering of cohabitation
and of Wars oppression and bloody
conflict but perhaps above all it is a
reminder of the people who once walked
here who came to this place to fulfill
their spiritual needs and to be closer
to the Divine whether they were Muslims
or Christians
I'll see you next time
[Music]
foreign